I was with a woman who already had a  child we had a child together but what  was very  um very apparent to me within that  relationship was that I was not allowed  to discipline this child the way I could  discipline my own child right because a  child still had the father in their life  the father would have something to say  about it if I disciplined the child in a  certain way and so I I there's a lot of  men out here saying that they wouldn't  get with a woman a lot of men saying  they wouldn't get with a woman who  already has a child because you get a  lot of the benefits sorry you don't get  all of the benefits of being a father  right but you have the responsibility as  a father